So who's my guest this week?
It's the courtroom artist, Jane Rosenberg.
Since 1946, broadcasts and photographs
of criminal proceedings
inside U.S. Federal Courts
has been strictly banned.
No matter how notorious the accused
or headline grabbing the crime,
media cameras are kept out.
Instead it is left to the artist
to be the eyes of the public
and capture the drama of the courtroom.
For the past 40 years,
Jane Rosenberg has come face
to face with those involved
in some of America's
most high profile cases.
She's sketched everyone from
El Chapo to Harvey Weinstein,
and her drawings have been
seen all over the world.
From the New York Courts
filled with Mob bosses
to those accused in the #MeToo
era, she has seen it all.
So what is it like
drawing Ghislaine Maxwell,
Jeffrey Epstein and Bill Cosby?
Here's what's coming up.
The now-convicted sex
trafficker Ghislaine Maxwell.
You were obviously making eye contact.
When did you realize
she was sketching you?
She had, she was leaning
on a piece of paper.
She took out a piece of paper
and she was going up and down
looking at me, looking at me.
So, you know, I knew she was sketching me,
you could tell when
somebody's sketching you.
And is it right?
I mean, I dunno if this is right,
but Weinstein asked for more
hair in one of your drawings?
He did, he was walking.
I was standing in an aisle seat,
and he was walking out with his lawyers
and he looked over at my sketch,
and he said, "Can't you gimme more hair?"
I just kept drawing and I
did not give him more hair.
Jane, thank you so much for talking to me
and to our viewers today.
It's lovely to be with you.
And I wonder how it does
feel to be the subject
instead of the one drawing
and creating the work?
I really hate it.
And that's why I don't think
cameras should be in the court.
Well, no, that would
slightly put you out of work.
But you've been in this line
of work for more than 40 years.
Yes.
And I just wanted to ask,
because the clip that has
gone, or the image, rather,
I should say that's gone viral recently
is of the now-convicted sex
trafficker, Ghislaine Maxwell,
drawing you as you drew her.
Yes.
That didn't make me nervous.
It didn't make you nervous?
No. Sketchers are fine.
I think if she took out a big fat camera
and put it in my face, I'd
feel a little differently.
But was that not quite an odd experience?
'Cause I imagine that
doesn't happen that often.
No, that-
It did happen to me about 30 years ago
when there was, there's a
comedian named Eddie Murphy.
I don't know if you know who he is.
Heard of him. Yep, definitely.
He did a little sketch
of me in a court case.
He was the defendant,
or he was actually suing
or some kind of dispute with his agent,
and he was bobbing up
and down and sketching,
making fun of me, you know, like pointing.
He did a little sketch
of me on a little Post-it
and he gave it to me and I have it here
in my apartment somewhere.
I found it within five years.
It's still here somewhere.
Okay. So once in 30 years,
it's definitely not the norm.
No, it's not the norm.
So it was odd.
You were obviously making eye contact.
When did you realize
she was sketching you?
She had, she was leaning
on a piece of paper.
She took out a piece of paper
and she was going up and down
looking at me, looking at me.
So, you know, I knew she was sketching me.
You can tell when
somebody's sketching you.
And it didn't put you off?
It didn't really put me off,
but I felt I better get this,
I better sketch this
'cause now this is what's
happening in the courtroom,
and I have to draw what I see.
Yeah, I was just gonna say,
I imagine that was pretty meta, you know,
you being drawn and her drawing you.
And also do you think there's a kind of,
is there a psychological
element to that, do you think?
There could be.
A lot of people are
throwing in their opinions
about what it means and
what it meant to her,
that she was trying to like have power.
I don't really know. I don't read minds.
I can't figure out what she was doing,
but I had to draw her
and I was really happy
she was looking straight
ahead as you may be right now,
because a lot of times I'm
seated right behind a defendant
and I can't see anything
but the back of their head.
So if I can get a front view, it's great.
A lot of times photographers
outside of a courthouse
will shout out somebody's name
when they're trying to get their image,
just so that they get
them to turn front view.
So it was an important thing for me,
and I wanted to keep it
going as long as possible.
It was great.
Well, that's interesting as well.
I mean, did you get to see what she drew?
Did she leave it on the table?
I did go running out.
It was a break and I went
out and ran after her lawyer.
I said, "Can I see? I'd like to know
what was she sketching?"
And she said, "You know, Jane,
I can't discuss that with you."
So I really don't know. I never saw it.
You're of course drawing as well,
and it has been a remarkable
time with the pandemic
where you have a lot of
people's faces now obscured
with the mask.
How has that been?
It's partly easier and partly harder.
It depends on who the person,
Ghislaine Maxwell had
great eyebrows and eyes
and good shape hair
because that's all I've got to work with.
It made it harder for me to
sketch because I use pastels
and I'm used to blowing
some of the dust off.
I'd be going,
but then it's in my mask,
so it was hard for me
to wear a mask and work,
but drawing everybody else in a mask,
it makes, it's not as
interesting, I'm sure,
to make a portrait of
somebody with a mask on,
but I had to draw what I saw.
Well some have also felt, you know,
it's hidden people's faces at the time
where you do normally get,
so even going into the
court, some people have felt,
it's been helpful to those
who are on trial in some way.
I think it's been hard
for a defendant's team,
the lawyers to pick a jury,
because you can't see their
faces, it's hard to read.
You wanna pick a certain type, you know,
when you're trying to select a jury.
I think it really made it
hard for the them to...
People look different when
they take their mask off.
I was working with a
reporter with a mask on,
and then I saw them outside with no mask.
I had no idea that was the same person.
No, I know. I've had that
exact same experience myself,
quite a lot of times.
And I just wanna see and check
that I've actually met that person before.
With this particular image,
'cause it really did captivate people.
I know you are not
actually on social media,
but this really did go viral.
I know you can keep the
images as well that you draw,
you submit a scan of
them or you give a copy,
and then you keep the original.
Have you been offered money?
Oh yeah. Sure. Yes.
Are, are you gonna sell it?
No, I'm not selling it, yet.
I have a collection of 40,
almost 43 years of sketches,
thousands of them.
And there's certain precious ones
that I think are more important
to me in my collection
to make it all worth whatever.
And I don't know, I'm
not ready to sell it.
Just about something
you were saying though
with Ghislaine, which is I
think speaks to your work
is that you've gotta draw what you see
and it's obvious that you have had
to take the emotion out of it.
Take my emotion out of it.
Yeah, exactly.
You have to-
Because if somebody else
shows emotion, I do have to put that in.
If somebody's crying,
Of course.
I have to capture their emotion,
but I have to try to not let my feelings
go into the drawing,
which sometimes I do have
reactions on some cases.
Sometimes I feel like, I cry sometimes,
and you know, tears are
really bad for pastels.
I just try to be neutral and journalistic.
I witness some horrific cases
and I see horrible crime scene photos.
Like I just did a Derek Chauvin case.
I watched that tape over and
over because it was shown
from several different angles.
And it was really hard for me to do that.
I had to look.
I had to look, I had to draw it.
I couldn't look away.
People have an instinct to look away
from a horrific scene like that,
but I had to really study the face.
It was just horrible to watch somebody die
over and over and over.
What impact has your work had on you
in your life outside the court?
I think, I do painting as well
and my subject matter is not crime,
and it's just cityscapes
of just more pleasant things, I think.
You know, I don't wanna see or
watch any crime scene movies.
I just need to escape it.
I don't touch pastels when I leave court.
I only will use oils in my painting.
No, 'cause I imagine some of
what you've been exposed to,
I dunno if it's made you,
has it changed the way
you feel towards people?
Do you sometimes think about
the worst things you've seen
and heard and maybe
struggle to trust people
or think of the bad things people can do?
I try. It's hard.
People's faces don't,
as I was saying to somebody
about Bernie Madoff,
he looked like such a kind old gentleman.
It would be so easy to
just fall prey to him
and like give him all
your money and trust him.
You can't really always
tell by somebody's face
what they're really like inside.
That's maybe something
I've learned from trials,
watching people.
You can't always tell.
There's brilliant con artists out there
who just can mask their true self
and you just have to be careful.
Have you ever been frightened in court?
I was once, I was
sketching a group of the,
I think they were the embassy bombers.
It was a group of terrorists,
and there were a lot of them
and they sat them all inside the jury box,
'cause they had nowhere else to put them.
And they let me sit in the well,
which is where the tables
for the lawyers would be.
And I was sketching, and
one of the defendants
jumped out of the well, lept over.
It was sort of like,
I think I had just seen a
Tarzan movie with my son
and he leapt over with both arms,
took his feet and started
running across the courtroom.
And the judge stood up and
pressed the panic button
and the marshals were standing in the back
and started running up and tackled the guy
against the wall right next to me.
It was terrifying.
I got on the floor, I held my pastel box,
I was really afraid,
which is resting on a
little tripod next to me.
I did not want that to go on the floor,
and I just squatted down
on the floor next to that.
So that was a pretty odd moment.
Well, I mean, if you are
regularly in the room
with big criminals,
something at some point
I'm sure is gonna go down.
That was the time that it went down.
And I had never been allowed in
to sit where I was sitting again.
They always, then it was just a time
where they just were extra cautious
since that point about
where they let anybody sit.
What's it like sitting
opposite household names?
I'm thinking R. Kelly and to
an extent Harvey Weinstein.
Okay. Household names.
These are all sex predators.
So it's, the Me Too era,
of a lot of the cases I've been covering
there's so many Me Too's.
What's it like?
I don't know, I think
they're all perverted
in different ways.
Like Weinstein, you know,
they all, there's just,
I think when people have a
lot of money, power and fame,
it corrupts them and they
just become deviants.
And is it right?
I mean, I dunno if this is right,
but Weinstein asked for more
hair in one of your drawings?
Oh yeah, he did.
He was walking.
I was sitting in an aisle seat,
and he was walking out with his lawyers
and he looked over at my sketch,
and he said, "Can't you gimme more hair?"
I just kept drawing, and I
did not give him more hair.
No, I imagine as a woman, and also someone
who just heard the
details you'd just heard,
but he's also still gonna be
someone who's used to power,
that that is not something you
would respond to pretty well.
He's not gonna have power over me,
so I did not give him more hair,
although many, many years ago,
John Gotti did ask me to
like shave off his chin,
a little double chin, and I did do that.
Oh, why were you scared of him?
Scared of him?
It was, I don't think I
was directly afraid of him,
but there were a lot
of Mob trials back then
in the eighties.
A lot of 'em.
I was surrounded by a lot of
Mafia people back then.
Trial after trial after,
that was like Me Too now,
back then it was Mafia
trials, Commission Trial,
John Gotti, the Pizza Connection Trial.
There was, I can't even
remember, they went,
there were constantly,
there were five different
families in New York
and there were so many trials
and they were switching-
I couldn't even follow it anymore.
They were switching power, like Gotti had
during the Commission Trial,
one of the defendants there had vanished
'cause Gotti had taken him
out and then he rose to power.
That was a whole different era.
It's interesting
that there will have
been phases like that.
The Mobs, now #MeToo.
Yes, that seems to be
the way the news works.
It's not, I hardly, I can't even think
of a Mafia trial I had covered recently,
maybe six years ago.
Nobody seems to care anymore.
Now it's #MeToo, #MeToo, #MeToo.
There was an era of financial crimes.
There was, you know, Martha
Stewart and Bernie Madoff.
And there were a lot of
financial crimes for a while.
And terrorists was a
big theme for a while.
And have you ever, I mean,
a lot of the people you've
mentioned don't get out of jail.
Some of them will, of course.
Have you ever met them in real life?
Once they get out of jail,
they probably serve such a
long sentence that I don't,
no, I've never met them
after their trials.
I'm usually onto the next trial.
How long do you have to make the drawing?
That all depends on if
it's an arraignment,
somebody during the Boston
Marathon bombing arraignment,
he was there for six minutes.
People timed it.
I usually have no idea,
'cause I lose track of
time and everything.
I'm just so, arraignments go very quickly.
And in six minutes I have to get
as much information down as I can
and then flush it out from
my memory, finish it up.
I can't obviously complete
it in six minutes,
but I have to have as much
information as I can get.
And sometimes I have a witness,
the same witness if I'm on a trial.
They may be on the stand
for days, the same person.
So I have a lot more time.
I might do a wide shot
with a lot of people in it,
take my time.
I might do a wide shot, a tight shot.
It varies.
So everything depends on
what I'm covering that day
and how much time I've got.
And early on I believe you
drew one of the first people
to be executed by
electric chair in Alabama
when it reintroduced the
death penalty, John Evans.
What was that like and
how did it impact you?
It was pretty awful.
The equipment malfunctioned.
Flames came out of the knee pad,
they came out of the helmet,
and I think they had
to redo it a few times.
I felt, I looked around the-
you don't see who pulls the switch.
And I look around the room
and nobody's, you know,
people are hands behind their back.
I felt very responsible, like I did it.
My hands felt dirty.
And then I remember driving home
during a thunder and lightning storm.
I had to go another hour away
to get to where I was staying,
and driving through puddles,
torrential rainstorm,
and I felt like this is a
message from the higher power.
And I felt like I don't
wanna be part of murder.
I think murder is wrong.
I don't think the government
should be doing murder,
and I don't wanna do it.
I don't believe in the death penalty.
So that was that in
terms of those drawings?
That was the only time I
covered an electrocution,
and yeah.
Wow.
You know, there are other horrible things,
as I just told you about
Derek Chauvin trial,
that was pretty hard to watch, and-
And I suppose being in New York as well,
there's a particular, as you've described,
there's a particular level
of crime at times, you know,
with the Mafia, a lot of violence,
there's been a lot that you've had to see.
And then you also have the celebrities
because a lot of the time,
this is where this happens.
Well, New York City is running a-
violence going on all the
time now, more than ever.
That's why I'm not plain air painting
on the streets of the city anymore.
I don't feel comfortable
standing out there
putting an easel up and
getting lost in an easel.
I don't know who's
gonna come up behind me.
There's a lot of
emotionally disturbed people
and there's a lot of violence,
and it's just horrific.
And the city is changing
and it needs to get fixed.
It's pretty bad right now, New York City.
So the trials I'm seeing, I feel safe.
I'm usually there's a lot of
court officers or marshals
or CSOs standing around.
I feel like I'm safe to draw there.
It's not like sitting on a subway
where somebody could get
angry if I'm sketching them.
Nobody's gonna come attack me.
You went viral again.
I mean, maybe you've
been viral lots of times
and you don't know because
you're not on social media,
but there was also another time,
which I think is smart a lot of the time,
because of your depiction of Tom Brady,
the American footballer in court,
over a cheating accusation,
people saying that your
picture didn't look like him.
I mean, that's not the same, of course,
as having art critics look
at your art for art's sake,
it's a kind of different lens on it.
But does that upset you?
Does that bother you?
It did back then a lot,
but I think I learned,
I had a lot of emails
and there's fans who,
it depended what team you're rooting for.
'Cause some people loved the sketch
and some people like, how
could I make him look so ugly?
You know, I don't tend to flatter people
when I'm doing quick courtroom sketches.
Well, I'd imagine
that not a lot of them
look their best either.
It's their day in court.
That's right.
They just come in, the fluorescent lights,
and they're like, "Get this
over with. Get me outta here."
Have you ever been surprised
by a famous person coming in
who doesn't actually really look
like you thought they would?
I just at the moment
remembered Uma Thurman
coming to court, who's very beautiful.
And she sat down in the witness box
and nobody would ever think
the sketch I made was her,
because you know, she's
not looking glamorous
and I'm sure there've been a lot of these.
I just can't remember them.
You've mentioned around your work
and how important it is to
capture what's going on.
And for you, I can tell
it's a very important part
of the justice system and transparency.
But what do you say to those
who think it's time for cameras?
Well, as I said in the beginning,
I don't really like being on camera.
I'm not comfortable with it.
I think it gives a lot of
power in an editing room
to the media.
They can make-
people don't-
when they see something on camera,
they believe it's the truth.
It's a photo. They don't lie.
But there is power in the
way things are edited.
Things can be shown, clips
of certain expressions
that may not show the truth.
When a sketch is shown, I
don't think people have that,
"Oh, this is the truth. This is where-"
It just captures a feeling
of what's going on.
So I don't, I think you have to watch out
with cameras in the court.
They may be quieter now,
they're not as obtrusive.
They don't make loud
clicking noises anymore.
All that may be true, but what is true?
What is the truth?
Well, I mean your, your
country, where I am,
this has been a big thing.
What is truth, post-truth
era, those sorts of things.
I suppose it's one of
those debates, isn't it?
And I'm interested as
well, as a journalist,
because of transparency in
courts and how we best do that.
Well, courtrooms are open to the public.
People are allowed to
come in and watch trials.
They're not sealed off
unless it's a sealed case.
And if a cameras running 24-7
in the courtroom, maybe that
will give more information.
But TV news tends to edit clips
of what they think is the
story they wanna tell.
And if the judge is yawning
they may show that and say,
"Oh, he's not paying attention."
And you know, anything could happen.
And I think there probably
are witnesses like me
who don't feel comfortable
in front of a camera.
Yeah. And also victims of course, as well.
Victims, of course, I can't
even sketch their likeness,
'cause I'm not permitted.
Not permitted to sketch their face.
So I have to, during Ghislaine
Maxwell and Weinstein
and plenty of cases,
I've had to draw featureless faces.
So I'd get the gesture,
maybe the tears, hands, hair.
But no, I can't really,
I can't let their whole likeness show
where somebody could pick them
out and say, "Oh, I know."
And jurors, I can't show their face too.
Especially anonymous jurors.
I mean, in the case of Ghislaine Maxwell,
bringing it back up, a lot
of people make a big thing
of what the person looks like
when they're found guilty.
People wanna read into
that moment, don't they?
Do you draw that exact moment?
That response to the verdict?
I'm watching what's going on, and I-
if she broke down crying, yeah.
I would draw that moment.
But she didn't really have
any reaction at that moment
that I could see.
Is that quite common?
Yes. It's common.
People don't always react.
Maybe they're in shock, I don't know.
Yeah. What a moment, what
many moments you've been in,
in people's lives recording the
biggest moment in many ways,
often for the very worst reasons.
But sometimes they are
exonerated as well, of course,
and that will be a very
important moment as well.
Speaking of Mafia trials,
the last one I did,
he was exonerated, and the
courtroom erupted with his fans,
like cheering, "Yay!"
And they ran out celebrating.
So that's rare though, yeah.
Jane, if you, could do it all again,
do you think you'd go
into this line of work,
knowing what you know about it?
Yes. I do love what I do.
I think I'm very lucky.
I love drawing people.
I'm very lucky I found a way
to earn a living doing it and feel safe,
and I love it and I would
do it all over again, yes.
Well, I've loved talking to you.
Thank you so much for letting us in
and letting me and us
turn the camera onto you
and focus on you for a bit,
but we'll let you get back
to focusing on others.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.